ariel sharon is fighting what might be
his last battle in this hospital near
Tel Aviv his doctors say he is in a
life-threatening condition after several
of his organs malfunctioned the family
of Israel's former Prime Minister are at
his bedside Mr Al Jarreau no is
hospitalized in our hospital for the
last seven years show some signs of
deterioration during the following two
days with some critical misfunction or
malfunction of some of its organs
including his kidneys Sharon suffered a
severe stroke in 2006 after serving five
years as Israel's Prime Minister he has
been in a coma ever since ah this is a
very sad moment for me because I was his
adviser for over 15 years and and it's
it's a very sad moment also for people
in Israel because Ali El shard was an
icon in Israel most Palestinians revile
Sharon calling him a tyrant though he
withdrew all Israeli troops from the
Gaza Strip he promoted the building of
Jewish settlements elsewhere and was
seen very much as a hardliner on
Palestinian affairs why